thank you
[Music]
all right this one's really you gotta be
careful with this one for real boys just
I know but like this be careful what
your opinion is being careful what we do
don't give a [ __ ] before you even really
who's gonna [ __ ] up the most okay bar
stick stick with that sticker I got that
same keep that same energy okay I want
to be careful this boys all right and
I'll tell you at the very end why you're
[ __ ] for that
all right so this happened that in New
York City Church in July you guys
probably remember church I'm out there
was a uh a live stream sermon
and in the middle of the Sherman uh
these basically like burglars came in
and I remember they was a stick up and
they robbed the people in the church
yeah and the pastor yeah and the pastor
they robbed them of jewelry like crosses
so that's how that whole thing was going
on on the live stream so it's one of the
mega churches then right it wasn't Omega
Church it was kind of like a smaller uh
church and then uh the pastor had
[ __ ] gold chains yeah a lot of people
had jewelry yeah we did that here and
then and then there was a follow-up that
we did where he um he was like um he
went on live again and explained it he
did yeah he did oh that's right but he
owed him money or something no he said
no he um he what happened was when they
were doing the report on like the amount
of losses they're like oh you're what
did you lose how much was it worth he
claimed a million dollars worth of
jewelry
oh that chain was Heavy though a million
but there's also emotional value
what's wrong with the priest being a
really good businessman yeah what's
wrong with this
nothing okay all right no we'll get it I
think because customers are donating
maybe I'm not supposed to be like that
oh I guess that's a valid point too
that's interesting because yeah I mean
this and then when you look at that
pasture he is like he's really like
well-dressed and he's got like nice walk
you get like seven rings and [ __ ] like
you could probably believe that if all
that shit's real it probably is worth a
lot of money so um I mean do you wanna
follow a bummy preacher though nope come
out I want to follow a guy that's like
yo you're successful
the guy that runs Lionheart Jiu Jitsu
decked out in gold and [ __ ] he better
I'm gonna talk to him now
hey dude you gotta change your image
gold chain weighing me down when I'm
being mounted in jiu jitsu why why would
I join a poor Jiu Jitsu gym why am I
getting mounted by you that thing should
be hitting you in the face I actually
think the equivalent for it the
equivalent for jiu jitsu should be like
does he have an assault record because
if he doesn't if he's not out here
assaulting people how can I even believe
his technique yeah that [ __ ] don't work
in the streets yeah but if he gets
caught isn't he shitty at it shouldn't
he be assaulting people getting away
with it that's a ninja school yeah well
then I guess the priests should be
stealing people's money and not showing
it then that's true
we're under like this [ __ ] you put the
you put it in yeah but he has but the
priest has multiple Refugee streams
that's like outside the church right
that's what it says in the article right
right Jose don't you want a God blessed
preach
yeah so
um people thought it was a little bit
weird that there hasn't been an arrest
made for like these Three Robbers
my job interesting it isurance fraud it
is being said that it is it's being
suspected that it is what do you think
Nick
I think
I think this guy right here
is in fact in a lot okay I think he's a
piece of [ __ ] yeah I think he's a
[ __ ] scumbag mother
son of a [ __ ] I think his mom is a
piece of [ __ ] too
great dope what else yeah I I hate him
yeah I think that jewelry not even real
it's not real not even [ __ ] real dude
hey what do you think about the robbers
how about the robbers I think the
Buddies
it's juicy small yay bro as far as I'm
concerned it's the two Jamaican dudes
that got hired were they Jamaican I
think the game plan was to Rob his own
church members and then they sell the
jewelry okay so that's a good that's a
good racket though all right I've done
that a couple times
I guess it's time to tell you there's a
couple guys who have little YouTube
channels like small like we have 80 000
subscribers that's nothing they covered
they covered this story
right yeah yeah sorry they are now being
sued for 20 million dollars each for
defamation by saying this guy was a hoax
see oh go ahead and I stand by
everything I said for what reason
where's my 20 million dude
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so Ryan I'm waiting for the time where
you tell me that we're [ __ ] right
here
I'm [ __ ] waiting oh and that's the
end of the video folks hey does anybody
have a lawyer
so basically hit a Bobby Hunter
not as simple as there's just two random
dudes that were just like watching the
video and going oh this guy's Faking It
these guys claim to know the pastor and
kind of know his whole [ __ ] oh and they
know his past rep and they've kind of
exposed him as being this like grifter
guy in the past that he kind of runs
these like scabs and [ __ ] they even said
that he's been spotted wearing that
exact same jewelry out in public and
others oh so they're hot they're they're
actually like onto them they're on to
him and they're like internet these are
like some I guess they might be like
some New York dudes that kind of like
it's in the same Community it's yeah
it's close enough or maybe they already
got conned by him once yeah yeah I don't
know the thing but that's the reason so
you're not gonna get us dude
is this with these shades on I'm [ __ ]
protected am I christosa Shades come on
I'm gonna say this I stand by what I
said and my name is Anthony Lee
and that's that's almost yeah and
coincidentally hey the dude though so
what the guy who's being sued like the
YouTube guy his [ __ ] quote when
they're like what do you think about big
suit is something like you would say he
goes I'm a commentator I give commentary
on religion public figures everything we
make a lot of jokes because this guy
really is a joke so for him to try to
even file something it's egregious hey
that's a joke dude that's what I think I
think that lawsuit is a [ __ ] joke
yeah just like his dumbass jewelry right
it's like a dumbass I bet he doesn't
know how to do an R Bar from guard like
me dude
and you're the silence rapper I said
that everybody was like what the [ __ ]
does that mean exactly [ __ ] exactly I
bet he's not owing one yeah yeah what's
his fight record yeah
I only know how to dance that's all I
know how to do
so you're both Anthony Lee we're both
Anthony we're both the leader of the
kinjas dude no you know what this he's
Anthony Lee I'm Mike song dude that's
right I'm Mike song actually no I'm not
my song I take that back I don't know
Mike song
that was a line I stepped on it but he's
still Anthony in terms of defamation
they are really making a lot of claims
they're saying that he that he's also
involved in drug dealing and [ __ ] and
that he's he separates with the Bloods
and Crips I never said that show these
photos I I don't know if I believe a
preacher who wears this type of outfit
I'm not a lie really
oh come on
you know God was rolling up in a
two-piece Gucci I think I think what he
did I think it's okay I don't think this
is an inside job anymore you should show
me pictures too just as style he's very
Godless that's a Rolls-Royce yeah he
moved his hand to show that too yeah
no one sits in a car seat like that like
that no I think he's he's of the Gods
bro I mean of the god of God
the Vatican is pretty pimp yeah but they
do a good job like putting their jewelry
in different ways that make it seem like
it's you know it's it's God's glory dude
why are you defending child molesters
wearing it all over the art this is the
Rose Romans
he's a bishop actually well the Vatican
does what he was they're like like yeah
no this is like all for God though this
isn't for us this is like for trippy for
God's house has to be nice yeah and
they're like they're like and like this
cheese danish is like for God and [ __ ]
yeah this can't be hard this caviar is
for Jesus too and like for all for Mary
oh so he's he's two he's two for me yeah
this guy's a little too much God's
creation
you gotta keep it up daughters of Eve if
he was in that photo with the with the
rolls and he's just like
yeah he likes it too much he needed to
do prayer hands
more prayer hands he was doing a prayer
hands he was doing like [ __ ] Tinder
hands he's like on the phone with Jesus
like there's like that picture's for
[ __ ] I know it's not forgot that
picture's for [ __ ]
okay okay okay I get it okay I think we
cracked the [ __ ] case what's the
third politician who said you don't want
a politician to have like to be driving
around like a piece of [ __ ] car do you
you want me to represent your community
in a [ __ ] Rolls-Royce or a Bentley
yeah even Bobby hundreds said that he
gets [ __ ] for not having it it's in that
like hey it's not me it's my community
that tells me I have to do it if I'm
going to represent my the people in my
community who voted me into office I
better do it in style to respect all of
you yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]